tel un style des halles j'accorde à son
journal oublierait louvel j'espère
qu'elles seront chauds sociaux tels
voyages grande porte à neuf et barzi
base son coup si les petites caméras le
monde
le petit écho de la forêt c'est la
trouverait il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de dissection ça vous le
découvrirez dans love qui découle la
forme
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons quelles sont les nouvelles
d'aujourd'hui auront voilà qui est
inquiétant pipo le piège ou hé tony
provost pipeau il ne bouge plus
pippo est très moche mal on y respire un
art hilda tu rigoles dormions tous le
poteau vous faites mais pipeau nous
sommes inquiets pour toi toi et les
couchers depuis deux jours et tous dans
tous les temps s'il n'y pas normal
bonjour votre bio je récupère bien et
les berckois deux forces bord du nom
tipi pour je t'apporte du fortifiant au
regarde de la baule ichi jeux prévus au
cordeau murs à lui la coupe du canapé
pas les laisser comme ça wade c'est ce
qui lui vaut un quad au docteur mimoun
en connaissons et mais moi j'en vois
déjà et je vais le chercher
divine music d'état là il revint deux
heures plus tôt heures un couple nu
brillamment l'ambré lente la vm docteur
est pas au crac il dit il oui le malin
de feghouli vos docteur theillier doubal
à désirer et moi j'ai des crampes
quand je cours trop vite mois à voile
parfois mal au dos et moi j'étais
vertige et titi titi tout le monde on
l'y attend je voyais fait venir pour la
lépi pour le pigeon au lit lui aussi mes
docteurs
il y est déjà donc il est malade c'est
ce que j'ai dit au revoir
pis tout l'monde suivi le célèbre
docteur hippocrate au chevet de ce
pauvre petit bout
ça va pas non je vais très bien merci
je vous cause de moi je lance que
ressentez vous mais répondez moi vous
m'avez d'une meute eux barry posant ce
que oui chez lancia non moi nous y
veillons mois sinon ils se baladent
étant malade très malade tu lances il a
l'oeil zones les plus risquées pas très
bien pour ça donc ce malade souffre de
fatigue générale que mon général donc il
lui faut du repos encore lui réponds
toujours du rebond au bout à part ça il
faut le faire manger chez le docteur
hippocrate se retira et le traitement
qu'il avait ordonné commence à mesurer
bioforum du tout bas question il faut
obéir au docteur rester au niveau du cou
y apporter aux bugs de la cigogne est
peu attendre fait deux mois qui fait des
allers-retours et c'est ce qui t'a
fatigué voilà ta bouillie à l'état pur
et ewa la téloche
je veux tu as tu le dr a dit qu'il
fallait et effet misé un communiqué que
tourmalet le lot 2 me pippo ne se
sentait pas très bien
le docteur hippocrate furent appelés à
son chevet silence
y ce malade et oman à la los cobos à
savoir tuer selon une digestion
donc il lui faut de la passion encore de
la diète tourner la diète 2,6 des mots
ce docteur hippocrate ne sait pas ce
qu'il veut comme tous les médecins
n'est ce pas cher téléphone à bientôt
pour une nouvelle édition du pratique ou
de la forêt